[Music]
what do you got there
oh it's just my wife emma this is my son
charlie
enjoy a lot less well last nothing
happier than the wife
of a new detective that was cool man
she's different you know my wife
you give a woman 600 tuesdays
it ain't worth three saturday nights how
much money you got a lot
how many problems you got a lot how many
people have doubted your life all
available units
are down detective banks in route
whoever did this has another motive
[Music]
they're targeting cops
this shit's gonna go sideways fast
someone's out there pulling all the
strings
you want to play games [ __ ]
what is storytelling
storytelling started with our indigenous
people
can anyone give me an example of a myth
or a story they're afraid of
lucas
what's going on we found a part of a man
in the woods today
[Music]
part of the man i guess the other half
was found
in the mine
well this has got to be an animal right
no animal i've ever seen
something is going on with lucas
these drawings belongs to a student of
mine
this is what was in the mind
[Music]
it's a diabolical spirit
excuse me this is a myth for you yeah
he is my responsibility
he's here
hey go on
hey neighbor you see anything weird
outside your house you tell me
all right
[Applause]
dad mom's being weird
[Music]
mom's always been weird what are you
doing up here yeah
don't let her in my son likes to play
hide and seek
can you bring him down i didn't say he
was here
you're a very stupid boy
can i help you you still at home down
here
baby you know your son dylan i don't
have a son
he had no idea who i was talking about
listen come on
he's gone i know it
i'd like to report a missing kid
are you okay ben where is your sister
i need you to tell me what's going on
[Music]
[Applause]
what is going on
[Music]
it's okay baby it's okay yeah
where oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
run
[Applause]
i don't know why you came all the way up
here there's nothing left
please there are people out there worth
[Applause]
saving
the people that are left another kind of
people worth saving
to downtown good morning that's me
millie
ordinary boring millie i love your dress
i think i saw it at discount bonanza
okay so i was never the most popular
homecoming's this weekend
booker is gonna be at the dance and boys
never really noticed me
[Applause]
honestly if this was a horror movie i'd
be one of the first ones to get killed
cute creepy dude in the mask like i said
but actually it turns out
where am i i didn't get killed oh my god
why do i sound like that
i woke up in the killer's body
the blissfield butcher strikes again
don't freak out you're black i'm gay we
are so
stop it's me it's milly hill hill
blissfield high
fill our glory and our might
and not only is that psycho wearing my
body he's killing it
he's like a wolf in sheep's clothing who
knows how many of our friends he's gonna
kill are you sure this is safe
no
[Music]
oh my god it's a slaughterhouse i have
like less than six hours to swap back or
i'm gonna be stuck in his body forever
hurry up loser i gotta take a dump i
have to admit it hasn't been all bad i'm
sorry
sir i didn't mean interrupt i move how's
that feel
i'll make you wish your stupid face was
never born
oh my god did you just pee yourself
oh what am i wearing i'm actually really
liking this for you
great we're gonna get killed by murder
barbie
[Music]
i can't wait to kill you time to stop
this [ __ ] we're in this together
i want my body back come and get it
look i know i look like the butcher but
it's millie he's crazy okay booker can
you look at me please
[ __ ] will you shut up
do you know what we wouldn't have found
if we want to stand on the trail
the waterfall
what is that oh my god
it's a story people know but don't talk
about
except in whispers like a ghost story
we don't bother them
and they don't bother us
[Music]
but anyone who goes up there what is
this place
[Music]
they don't come back
[Music]
it's happened before
[Music]
descendants of these people are still
living up there on the mountain
[Music]
they said they would be the foundation
on which a new nation would be built
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
huh
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
let me get you
i saw something out there
[Music]
someone
the largest organism on the planet looks
right here
growing waiting
and it's ready to spread
safe without your voice
[Music]
b
it
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
in the name of our lord jesus christ i
command you to give me your name
and cut nice job everybody
here we go three two
time to go on script
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to willie's wonderland spend the
night cleaning willy's wonderland
and i will pay to have your car fixed
deal
you are officially on staff let's get
the hell out of here
i can't stand to hear a grown man scream
this place has a dark history
i know the [ __ ] story they told you
it's a lie
you're here to be a human sacrifice
have you been listening to a word i've
been saying
he's gonna die in here but he won't
listen to me
[Music]
nobody is safe put your balls on heaven
we're going to willys
he's not trapped in here with them we're
trapped in here with him
a few words
the sickness hangs over the city like
putrid fog
bodies are piled higher than narrow
streets
it's as if the day of judgment has
finally arrived
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll give you some advice leave tone
while you
can i saw it the other day
she was acting bloody peculiar there's
only one thing that can explain it
she made a pact with the devil
no way to run witch
what's to happen to me they'll try to
break you
like they did to the rest of us
fear not my child salvation is at hand
[Music]
just the devil inside
my will is greater than yours
nobody's safe
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
[Music]
this
i'm gonna scale from one to ten how
bad's my rig
i drilled to the bottom of the ocean and
we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how will you
even get there
we walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
[Music]
what was that it's really tough
what is happening
listen i have a story for you something
the examiner will love
a healing possibly divine
a girl performing miracles after a
visitation from the virgin mary
in chicago new york dc every demographic
on this planet
is eating this up give me the exclusive
all right i think i got this all set up
what do you say we do a couple
real easy questions how many are gonna
watch mary wants to reach as many people
as possible
maybe millions
there are people out there that don't
believe in your miracles
how would you respond to those folks
[Music]
seeing is believing and why do you think
mary chose you
i opened myself up and welcomed her in
witnesses of the virgin mary draw
millions of faithful
each year the vatican's been tasked to
investigate
this visitation from the blessed virgin
i have read several libraries worth on
the supernatural
investigate half of those miracles
prove him all false
[Applause]
[Music]
she's here you think there could be
other forces at play here
when god builds a church the devil
builds a chapel
next door don't doubt her
doubt weakens faith
[Music]
hail mary full of grace pray for us
sinners
now and at the hour of our death this is
not the work of the virgin mary
it's the work of the unholy
faith in evil and poverty love
believe in her
offer your soul
to mary
holy mary mother of god the lord
[Applause]
[Music]
you get the truck come back with the
money that's
2.5 million dollars per head
if you come back alive
[Music]
tile
[Music]
foreign
i'm anna fox there are some things that
need to be said about me
i have an anxiety disorder
i live across the street my mom asked me
to give you this i'm not prepared for
visitors
i'm a agoraphobic i can't go outside
[Music]
you let some of the outside come in your
neighbor from across the street
pretty sure you're not supposed to be
taking these with alcohol
her name is jane russell she's become a
friend
like your earrings oh thanks a gift from
an old boyfriend
does your husband mind you could feel my
pain our family's complicated
[Music]
nypd why is he here mr russell believes
that you made a mistake
you have never met my wife we spent the
evening together
i'm jane russell she's not jane
i know what i saw your doctor said that
your meds
can cause hallucinations why are you
protecting them
they're all hiding something
[Music]
i heard earring it's in their house
you're playing with the wrong family
do they know you're here alone
9-1-1 i think somebody is in my house
don't go looking into other people's
houses
you won't like what you see
well how was camp any good digs awesome
we're here hey
[Music]
this is my boyfriend john it's a
pleasure to finally meet you
i hope you don't mind that i'm here i
know it's your lake house and i'm not
trying to take away time with your mom
it's important to me that you're okay
with this i'm happy for you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how did you guys meet i've been at the
lake all year studying a few species
here
you're kind of a weird dude i guess i am
but i mean weird is cool right
do you always lock the doors when you
sleepwalk i saw you walk into the lake
towards this light
i'm pretty dry
i love
[Music]
we're gonna be a family we have to learn
how to forgive
and forget right lips
get off of him
he's here
[Music]
hey wait we gotta try it try what
calling the empty man where's the empty
man
if you're on a bridge and you find a
bottle you blow into it
and you think about the empty man
oh come on mandy how old are you it's on
the rest
on the first night you hear him and on
the second night you see him
and on the third night well on the third
night he finds you
he finds you
[Music]
you can hear him squirming his way into
your thoughts
like a disease and his message is
contagious
[Music]
what up kids it's cole this is erl
i've traveled all over the world looking
for the wildest experiences to entertain
you guys
you watched commented and told me what
to do next i challenge
all of you to find something that scares
me i dare you come on
we are taking you to an escape room
experience in moscow
i have a buddy named alexi he wants to
take us everywhere
i'm talking the best clubs the best
restaurant this guy's so rich that
everything he does
is the best i've been to escape rooms
man but not one like this because they
make it just
for you you have to be invited look i
get that there are two sides of you
there's this public hole and there's
this private cold
i just don't really know the real you
remember
as real as everything might seem you're
safe
sketchy at all it will begin streaming
it
directly into your device from the
cameras
let's do it this is crazy
hello
what's going on
[Music]
what happened here what the hell is this
this is your guy you was just talking to
him i don't know him all that well what
we were in russia with some guy that you
barely know are you crazy
we don't have our phones our wallets our
passports anything we need to leave now
they change it every single time it's
intense but it's a game
i couldn't say nothing earlier because
he is always watching
hello cole how do you know my name
is
what if this is still part of it no we
lost look at the timer
please let her is just
a go more selective than yours
[Music]
wait oh yo delete that last part no dude
this is live
hello
[Music]
hello
police department
this is matheson
i'm detective
i'm muldoon talk to you about a woman we
found
will you feed me
excuse me
william they always used her feet
william was your husband yeah
ma'am are you alone in the house right
now
are you alone
will you help me please
stay there i'm gonna get it
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
there is an elevator in the elevator
you press the button to the floor with
no name
behind those doors there's a life
you always tremble
[Music]
the plane it's here this weekend
you will be our guests here anything
and everything is possible no service
it's not everything is possible good
evening
i'm mr rurik let me officially welcome
you to
fantasy
[Applause]
i'm curious how this all works what if
your fantasy involves a
person from your life holograms like
tupac what if it's somebody who died
tupac so what's your fantasy revenge on
a childhood bully
your life is about to change
[Music]
i hope you're ready
that is a really good hologram there is
only one fantasy per guest
[Music]
and you must see your fantasy through it
brought her back to life
no matter what
oh my god that's really her
work this is not what i meant what the
hell is this place
people die here the island's twisting
what we asked for
we weren't brought here to have our own
fantasies
we were brought here to be a part of
something else
i'm your friend i always wanted to hear
you say that
[Music]
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend had burned her
ileana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Applause]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it until it
kills you
[Music]
he's there
we can get out of this together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this poor souls journey has come to an
end
from dust we started to dust we return
every corpse tells a story but it's our
task to listen
so these are all stories about how
people died
[Applause]
some tales even i find too unsettling to
recount
she's dead you gotta get that body out
of your apartment
keep your doors locked tonight keep an
eye out for crazies
that's pretty cool yes it isn't
[Applause]
your story is just beginning
[Applause]
when you see someone change in front of
you
[Music]
and you know there's no going back
scares me to death
no one's been here in months it's
beautiful
i love you though i love you too does
anyone need a refill yes
please have you seen this out here
before
it's in the trees it's all over
something in the air
i felt a little light-headed before i
feel good
it's like i was knocked out i can't
remember
mr turner
miss turner where's mr turner
it is so nice out today
hello what is going on i don't know
something from the water
i can feel it inside
[Music]
i'm just having so much fun how are you
in the hospital
don't be scared don't be scared
[Music]
m
is
[Music]
this is ludwar
there is something very very wrong here
we have to go now
it won't let you lead
mrs litvak what won't let me leave
will make you see terrible things
will find another broken person
dude i'm home
[Music]
dude
gotcha it's fun to be scared sometimes
huh
it's bad it's just the dawn it's pretty
violent
i understand that some of jude's
behaviors would be upsetting
but i urge you to find a place where he
feels safe
i think it would be good for him good
for all of us
oh my goodness look at that that must be
the main house come on dude
[Music]
it looks like he was broken before and
put back together
who's this handsome jet brahms how'd you
come up with that
he tells me all sorts of things
okay i just think it's a little bit
creepy
is this your new friend bronze what are
some of the things you talk about
the other families he's lived with
[Music]
gonna take the doll away from him yes
just a whisper first
something is happening to him
[Music]
he knew your boy would find him
[Music]
love you mommy i love you
[Applause]
[Music]